[Music]
one of the things we consistently talk
about here at the Rubin report is why
it's important to judge people as
individuals and not as a collective you
as an individual are much more than your
immutable characteristics be it your
skin color your religion or your
sexuality to judge you on those
characteristics is actually what the
essence of prejudice really is prejudice
of course means to prejudge so if you
look at a black person or a Muslim
person or a gay person and think that
you know what they think or more
importantly how they should think based
on those characteristics then you are
actually the one who's being prejudiced
sadly many of the people who accuse
others of bigotry and racism these days
are often the people who practice this
brand of prejudice the most without even
realizing that they're doing so just
look at some of the things that my
friends larry elder Maajid Nawaz and
ayaan Hirsi Ali are called
by the so called tolerance side when you
look at a group of people and you think
you know what they should think or
what's best for them based on those
outward characteristics and not what's
going on in their own minds you not only
lock people into your preconceived
notions of what they are but stifle the
voices of the minorities within these
minorities this is why the voices of
black conservatives and gay Muslims for
example are so relevant and interesting
today if you really listen to these
minorities within the minorities you
will judge these people on their
thoughts their logic and their reason
instead of simply how they look or who
they love in a way the very existence of
these free thinkers within these
minority communities flips identity
politics on its head showing the flaws
of this postmodern intersectional way of
thinking just see how quickly those who
preach identity politics turn on black
or Latino people who have conservative
political beliefs or how easily they
dismiss gays or women who dare talk
about how poorly they're treated in
Islamic societies identity politics only
works if you believe that the most
important quality about each of us are
the attributes which we are born with
thus cannot change rather than the ideas
which we come to learn I view this
twisted ideology as a true
essential danger for the tolerant and
liberal albeit flawed country that
America is Martin Luther King Junior's
desire for his children to be judged by
the content of their character and not
the color of their skin is being
undermined by the very people who
purport to be the tolerant ones
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the CEO of the Thurgood Marshall College
Fund Johnny C Taylor the organization
represents nearly three hundred thousand
students who attend the 47 historical
black colleges in America today
I heard Johnny speak at an event in
Dallas a couple months ago and was blown
away by his passion his commitment to
educating young people and his desire to
move past identity politics we're going
to talk about politics race and much
more has the role of the black college
changed as we've become a more fair and
just society that's just one of the many
questions I'll ask Johnny and I'll only
judge him by the content of his answers
not the color of his skin
[Music]
you
[Music]